Hey, how you doing?
Doing well, how are you?
I'm good. I'm glad that uh, I'm glad
that we were able to catch up.
Yeah, I didn't.
I just like bail on you again.
(laughs)
It's all good, tell me what you want.
what's been what's been keeping you busy.
So, hold on here.
It said it's warning me that I--
echoing for you is that right? You are
not echoing for me.
That's it, Google.
Well, OK.
Okay, so I did do um...
like so summit eight started LLC
did some just like little locals.
stuff and then I actually will originally would
because SBM was going to bring me on.
to do like social and things.
they were struggling with. You know, it was one of those things like...
When I was leaving, it was like...
It's see you later. I'm sure by the end of the summary.
you'll be back. I'm sure, you know, it's like, okay.
cool like my goal in life is to not.
But I would never like
I told Nick I'm like, I'll never take it off the table
because I'm gonna--
for my bills, you know, like I want to provide for my bills.
my family since then they've gone.
their CMO additional.
I don't really get the inside scoop, it's very like...
Hands off I basically only keep
been touching. I think with like...
- Definitely because it's been...
The whole thing was so weird honestly.
all went down and...
Yeah, anyway, they've given me like very...
Well Steph's very open about it. She's okay.
- Okay.
- It's at all, you know.
I mean, she's like.
always an angry like angry. That hasn't.
changed, I guess.
- Better, yeah.
Um, so anyway.
That was originally the plan, then I was like...
Verde had reached out to me to help out with a couple of things for
like process documents, I actually ended up.
Get in another opportunity.
that was going to take a different project.
And so I actually put them in touch with Erin to do some of them.
And so she did that.
And I have been.
working pretty much exclusively with it.
building maintenance. So there is
Advanced Building Maintenance Inc.
Out of...
Sacramento, it's like, come on.
And they...
So then, like, yeah, later.
I started kind of tip-toeing into that space.
They put me on a retainer essentially because I
I wanted to hold on to my benefits.
as long as possible.
They were
killer from SBM once you hit like that VP.
He, yeah, so she, man.
There's like no one will ever beat those, honestly.
- I don't know.
- 'Cause I think it's like you had the...
you know, seriously.
looking out for their own interests like Nick, that.
and they're co-abricating for the best benefits in the whole world.
feel like so. There's a.
right after them. So yeah, we were holding on to
to those as long as possible.
I actually just went W2 with them.
So.
No, I'm announced. Um.
Because, frankly, it's like...
little teetery here over here. I came.
to like a totally different language.
landscape that I actually understood.
prior to getting involved.
The company, what's really cool is...
is, and then I wanna hear about your story,
so I'm gonna give you my little--
- No, no, no.
- No, I wanted to hear all this.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so the company, they...
basically they grew by 45.
percent last year. So you can
imagine the strain that that put on the organization.
Just--
investment in people.
like the
literal like they expanded from 13.
States to 26.
That was not smart honestly because it's like
should be doing like
concentrate
you know, so I was brought in.
I'm working with them. So just to give you a heads up, Mike.
Parker was his president of the company.
from SVM. Did you guys overlap?
No, the name rings a bell though.
He was like COO, hit up Charlie.
is right hand for like 25 years but
the actual heart and conscience.
of the man, you know.
He's like a very kind.
I think if...
If I say Christian, I mean it in like the best possible way.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm tracking, yeah.
Yeah, but not in like a...
Whatever.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Well, and it's not like the cafeteria.
Christianity that you see on TV all the time.
You know, we're just like let me grab this
and not that. And it.
Yeah. But I-
Yeah, religion, we don't need to go into it.
out my thing, but he's like very sweet and like
guided by a higher moral purpose.
I'll say that.
He's like, I trust him is what I would say.
Yeah. So, and it was sweet.
He really randomly, like James done.
I can't hold him that I was on the market.
They were like some golf tournament or something.
jail on schmoozing because Mike after leaving.
being SBM went to JLL.
Okay, yeah, then came over.
And he
Yeah, James is complaining.
He said something like that.
like you might wear Jenn Kearns like she was she was
Picking ass helping me like land this Wells Fargo
like I was working like daily with him on some projects
like hand in hand.
and honestly not that close and on hand.
and in hand literally but but now he's like he's little.
Well, I was schmoozy. But yeah.
So he was like, yeah.
And then--
And Charles just, you know, up in like, up people, like the...
The whole department, this craziness, blah blah blah,
goes on and he's like, "We--"
about it, Jim Kurz you know so he knew.
that they were at this like critical juncture from a city.
and marketing perspective and they just didn't even have marketing.
But not only that, the real issue is that they had...
Mike Abercrombie and Darren Marino, do you remember either?
of those they were SBMers.
Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
Here.
During was sales, Mike was off.
He was one of those like VPs over a region he had.
northern.
California for a while.
But they are a safe space.
obviously, but they are not.
Um, exactly.
material and say like very the very.
sketchy, shady, like they're...
They'll do anything for a deal.
You know what I mean?
I mean, and like they were underselling just to win.
because are the owner of advanced.
is also it's a
self-made company, right? Like he and his brother, he was
tell the story of my brother and I went door to door knocking with mop
buckets in our hands. It's just like, you know, like, I was like,
Okay, well, let's think about like positioning a little bit.
I think that there's a heart-string play here,
but like...
you know, you were now dealing on the national scale.
We can't be talking about, you know, so we've been.
We've been doing that.
Some coaching.
But he's a great guy in terms of like the first time I met him.
and I literally didn't stop smiling the whole time, right?
like he, cause he was just showering me.
phrase can't believe that he can have people on his too.
this caliber because he's never
like he always looked up to Charles Summers as this like.
Uncuttable. He's from Sacramento. He's seen...
the rise of that organization.
And he--
wants to follow, right? So he went from door to door.
or office cleaning to now about 100 million.
year. And so but he the
Here's the best part.
And this is where Mike Abercrombie and Darren.
sort of like got away with murder for a while,
is that...
Pat did not, the owner did not.
retire from his day job, which is
is crazy. He had a D job. He had a job.
working in what was SAC Val at the time now.
I think Brady, but like the supplier.
supplies and consumables. And so that was
his daytime job.
And so he was able to give himself
discounts it is nighttime like
go vacuum and whatever, but he became his number one cut.
customer, right? So.
So killer margins on that stuff for him.
But he stayed in business.
I mean, he stayed in that job until like.
up to like three years ago or something.
And...
And he's in his 60s, you know, I mean, he's just a hard.
worker like any just understands the business.
is so well because of axes,
he's just been boots on the ground this whole lot.
life, you know.
But Mike and Darren sort of
have their run, you know, during.
like, paths away and Pat just wants to see
top line growth.
And then my--
was brought on because there were some issues that just administrative.
I'm Mike Parker.
Well Mike Parker realized.
My Abercrombie and the Obstacle isn't working.
You can...
work at SBM, you got kicked out at SBM.
So like...
Now we're gonna hear you there.
So you brought in GAP.
be ditty, which she will.
was a, she was SVP at SBS.
of, well, procurement on her way out.
but she's the one who managed and landed the whole mark.
account. Like she did.
all of it and then like BMS, all of the life sciences on
the east. She's headquartered out of Philly.
So we just opened up a divisional office there.
but she is now there's been just
so much like, people, it's crazy.
There's a tiny, like, art.
executive leadership. What's that?
Yeah, yeah, this is a lot.
She's the CEO.
So she was brought in because everyone's
It's like we're not making sense of these accounts.
Like we're not making sense.
losing money or da da da da da da da and she's like
what the hell is happening here?
Like you guys are selling shit.
can't perform, you know, and so she really.
started looking under the hood.
as all this is happening in this
This is top secret, but won't.
The only reason it stops here is because I--
I don't know, our owner hasn't shared it,
but,
pushing right now, but we have taken
investment from a tech.
Well, and we have taken on private investor.
And he is the owner of the house.
of the Sacramento Kings.
he's yeah. And like.
super connected in Silicon Valley.
So like after this call, I'm like meeting with my friends.
one of his VC heads of VC.
And honestly, it's really crazy.
to be on the call with these billionaires.
And in like--
>> Not Charles Billy.
where they can like fire me today, you know?
'Cause he owns...
like a small person, I'm not a small but a smaller person.
a minority percentage of the company. No one knows.
And I keep telling Pat like
We need to be transparent about this number one.
from a client perspective.
you know, we're still like a privately held we're not.
public, it's not like, you know, but um
Yeah, we're doing a lot of lead.
things that we're just need to because they did this like in a vacuum.
I'm truly no one new like Mike Parker
in Pat and the CFO at the time who's.
been replaced because there were all these things that like
They changed their name and no one knew.
I just...
on this out last week.
And I'm like,
every registration, every RFP, every invoice.
All of this stuff needs to be done.
be changed and do you know what a mess that is in a CBRE?
system or a JLL system. Oh my god.
and no one thought about it.
And they changed it to something like.
terrible. I was like, can we like, if
If we had a chance because advanced is like...
advanced what, right? Advanced facility.
Now you think I'm talking about smart facilities.
And there's 150 of them.
first exercise I did when I started consulting with them was
like you gotta change the name.
I mean, not even
like it just gives you an answer.
Someone calls them in.
which worked, it worked for a minute.
minute when people accidentally call them they like
I think they have a couple of clients that like access
accidentally stumbled upon them.
but it's not helping them now, particularly.
with the IFMs kind of like parting ways with ABS.
you know, and because they're in the...
the same pond now, you know, so yeah.
It's a sh*t show.
But basically the deeper we've looked,
the worst it looks, frankly, financially.
like they're not making money.
They were.
45% growth last year.
And they got rid of Darren, they got rid of Mike.
You know, they--
kind of like offload some of these people who...
Frankly, we're tanking the company.
and almost sabotaging.
Like there were just--
some shady, shady things happening.
And like...
The crappy thing is the...
You know, you can't do non-competes necessary.
early right now, you know, in any more, but they truly
like sabotage and kind of disparage the order.
organization, but the companies.
not in a position to litigate really.
Like they don't wanna go.
spends what 50-year-olds?
minimum to start, you know, like they knocked onto
and we're like, you can't be doing these things, but.
Anyway, they've now found...
Homes are different competitors.
And so it's just
the trail those guys.
left. I mean, we are cleaning up masses truly every day.
just even perception in the way they connect.
business and Darren wasn't as bad but my
man. Nice to your face, but super
shady guy and and I always have the X.
like I should have trusted that.
The one thing that I'll say though is
So everything switched up, my personal.
was president over the whole thing. And now...
how he's moved into a growth in person.
partnership side so really just sales because they got rid of
Abercrombie and Darren.
and there's no sales.
They...
They ended up the marketing process.
person they had on board. She was like the RFP person.
unqualified.
And she kind of saw her way out when I started asking like, hey.
So like, can you just let me know?
She'd say, oh, sorry, I can't meet,
'cause I have a meaty.
and I'd be like, oh, who are you meeting with?
You know?
And--
She seriously, I asked her to speak.
just send me like an update of her week and she.
resigned. And I was like, okay, she found out she was a
So she was not.
actually working. You know it's like
She had work based on deadline like an
RFP, but she was not a train right like she
not a writer she but...
So then I've been truly doing.
Everything, like I first came on to do just.
like brand overhaul like we had a you know a nice
scope of work that was like, okay, these are the things we're going to be.
focused on website, you know, the standard.
And then it's just like...
Daily maintenance and now sales kind of.
like I'm going to conferences, I'm doing calls.
So it's totally like it's not somewhere I necessarily would.
wannabe. I mean sales is like obviously
a place you can make money, but I can't do
all of it. So I've been supporting Mike Parker.
because he's moved into growth and in
frankly, he's very old school. He doesn't have any.
the knowledge of AI, even the things that
I pulled for him and I built for him.
He's like...
So I don't understand this just you found this online
to exit someone made this and you found
I know and I'm like
No, my, like, look at the variables.
I'm like, let me just--
show you what this prompt is because I'm trying to show them like look at
This isn't just like, because he's like, "Well, I try."
to ask chat GPT once and I'm like okay let me see what you're doing.
you asked it, you know, and it's like,
it doesn't really,
understand and I'm building like interact.
tools with a clot and like you know just various
things that I'm like check like check this out.
you know, building calculators and things for him to kind of like
and then...
Oh yeah, he's not really picking it up.
So I've been helping on every one of his bits.
RFP like response.
design a little bit, all these things and
And now I spoke with a--
our owner on Friday and he's like,
I want you to--
potentially move into like a sales leadership role.
eventually and I want you to like build a sales team and I
I want you to start running your own pipe.
and, you know, do some daily calls.
on clients and and I'm just like all the
whatever it takes to pay my bills, but I will tell you.
you that's not my strength you know and I told them that.
And he's just like, yeah, but you have the personality.
You could totally do it.
I'm like, you're not hearing me, you know?
and um.
There are so many good things about the job, but it's just frustrating.
there was even a layoff last week where like four people.
who are pretty tenured, were let go and I'm looking
at the books going, because I have like full access to everything.
very transparent in terms of
of, you know, that's a nice thing about this company.
I'm just direct top.
echelon right now, you know, and so I can access
you know a lot of the insights and I'm sitting here
like how long is this gonna last? Because I make a
a lot more than, like it's an easier cut.
know what I mean? Like to say just let's get rid of.
But then they shoot themselves in the fun, because I'm doing all the things.
the RFPs and all of the sales.
and all that they have no one.
So.
I'm in a weird spot for Carrias that I'd--
wasn't like a couple months ago.
But frankly, I was just talking with Gabby,
and I was like,
Hey, I want to tell you I'm kind of pissed you guys brought me into this
shit. Like I had good stuff going.
last year, like when I was like, oh yeah, she's--
like I didn't know either like I would never have you.
She didn't, she wasn't aware.
She's like, I would never have advocated for each other.
to come in and I was like honestly I had other like
like opportunities and I'm just disappointed.
that this is kind of where we're going.
And I was like,
I believe we can turn this around, but it's going to take a--
I'm a like buckle down.
make this happen and I don't know that they have the patience.
You know, and so not it's
literally just the owner because he's...
I personally believe he's looking for an exit.
in a year as I think he's trying to.
like offload and ratchet up.
Yeah.
So he can just let go.
And so that's where like I'm trying to get it.
now with the VC side so that...
if they do take over the company.
I mean, I don't know.
that I'd be here in a year, but they do take over the company.
they see value. Like they've already been excited.
about some of the things I'm talking about,
so I'm like, I'd rather...
Honestly, take me off the books and I'll go join them.
you know, help with their man.
of like 20, 30.
companies and they don't have marketing.
don't have someone looking at brand and
and positioning.
So that's sort of where I'm--
I'm trying to provide.
I'm trying to--
just strategically wiggle in.
there, but we'll see.
Yeah.
So that's where the--
That's where like the security
is a little bit more where they're just looking to spend money.
like I can help you with that.
And so everyone.
every few weeks they'll set.
and we a new company to evaluate.
and like meet with, they want my opinion.
So I'm like, okay, it's free right now because they're minority owners.
like in theory they get x percent of my time right.
It's not really agreed upon.
I'm like, I'll be happy to do it just again.
for that street cred and like give them an analysis of like.
new tech and new.
tools and there's light application within our--
our business but it's not necessarily like.
fully where they were.
would want. I mean, I would never be entertaining these meetings.
normally, you know, but they're like having me.
sit in and anyway it's it's cool so there are things
things I like. There are things that are a little concerning.
And yeah, so.
How are you?
She's great.
Um, I mean, she's ADA.
So she's doing well. Yeah, she's doing well. She
um really is doing great like
She fully recovered from her hip surgery.
And all that because that was when yeah
And I was just starting to kind of like work with this group.
around then and that's that was
Whereas like, okay, this is, I'm so glad I'm at,
consultant because I can make my time at that time, you know?
I could just say yeah I'll get my hours in.
this way, right? But, um,
Yeah, it was tough.
Things have been crazy.
with family with that.
Yeah, we're good.
So what happened with Facilities Group?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(upbeat music)
Oh my gosh.
I was gonna say you guys had so many right I think
Advanced just took over from Facilities Group.
on Puget Sound energy.
(upbeat music)
Thanks for watching!
Yeah, so it went...
from BGIS to advance I think is what.
Yeah, so, oh, BJ, yes. Yeah, but then they.
had multiple subcontractors.
in the area and said they were not managed.
that. Like there is no oddity or kind of
quality management, you know, like there's no continuity.
which is a dog of an account.
honest there's nothing valuable. The only thing is that
helps us have like a deeper concentration in Seattle.
So we're like, we'll take it, but.
I mean, it's like route work, you know.
(audio cuts out)
(upbeat music)
Mm-hmm.
I know, I'm like also just siphoning
everybody's drinking water.
Thank you.
Thank you. Yeah, we're thirsty.
I'll just keep dreaming.
I'm thinking out of my SBM cop don't call.
Do you see?
Yeah.
*sigh*
Yes. Oh, yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think honestly, okay.
a couple things.
I definitely think like right now.
Now it's not, I can't add anything.
I wish.
I, you know, like bring in people, but.
That's not to say that couldn't happen on like a project basis.
down the road particularly right now we're doing.
a lot of like, give me work where...
CBRE is just like here you go.
Not really, but it's like provide pricing.
And we'll get back to you know, we'll
get to the client because a lot of we're doing the CBRE local.
right now, a lot of it where it's--
We are working directly with the sales people as they're.
just kind of cold calling and canvassing and they too.
who asked their sales team.
But--
They are just...
throwing prices out to
everyone. So it's just it's like that's where some of the
tools that I've been building was there.
out of necessity. We're like, I can't keep up on it.
with this. We can't. It's a waste of time too because you're
getting involved too early.
You know, it's like, they just wanna...
ballpark quote. They just want a
general estimate that they want to also seem
knowledgeable when they go back to their clients, you know, so they need to be able to
not just say hey yeah it's 25 grand.
How'd you get there?
Someone told me.
Right, you know, so there's
There's been a lot of work that I put into that, but...
But we don't very often have these big.
complex age or get bids.
Now when we do.
do, we don't know what the hell to do honestly, you know.
like as an organization. I've led a couple.
of them like bms because up
against SVM and it was like, I was like, okay guys, good luck.
We just did Wells.
Fargo. That was a
little bit less involved as kind of like JLL standards.
but when you get into the eye
as you know, pharma, government.
any of those, it can get really overwhelming.
And so that's
That's when I would certainly advocate.
could speak to your value.
where I feel like you are all
is so valuable too is just in the
strategy in the presale right in the
market intelligence that was
Yeah, honestly, like that sales...
you know, Intel like the
the early on kind of being part of that in the end.
and like giving the people the tools to pursue.
That was always where I was like, "Man, we're under..."
to re-utilize into me.
And I think you could have--
worked into that space, just that environment.
it was awful. But yeah.
I mean, I will absolutely keep you in mind.
And I'll also pass your info.
under like my brother just started a Pinterest. He's leading
the team of yeah he's I know he's
Well, he was at Google and YouTube.
He's the one.
that he has, I'm like, if you look at my brother, J.
Miss Encurrence. JMI.
So, hi. (laughs)
Yeah.
He...
Yeah, he...
the team he has the
And for basically making YouTube profit
right? So he.
was given the reins to building.
team to help monetize this.
Just slug of a company.
that Sergei owned and, you know, anyway.
So it's like he...
I feel like I already liked it.
thing. So that's basically like...
He did, that is like AR.
He was part of their AI team.
So now you--
She's a Pinterest.
They did like, Google did a whole like overhaul.
where they outsourced a lot of his his a
I like team his um.
to Brazil. I was like, where Brazil?
And then they tried to call them all back.
you know and they were like yeah so
So he's a Pinterest now.
I think he won.
Was it Yahoo for a minute?
Yes, because I was like...
What is this 1992 calling?
like what is y'all is like okay.
I'm like maybe not 92, I like 2000.
to. But you know he's like
like no I'm bringing Yahoo back like he was joking.
But it was just sort of a carry, like a--
help him kind of bridge, but now it.
Pinterest, he's building a new product.
And so he's building a whole team.
I don't know if he...
He has a need for like RFPs, but he's definitely in great.
He's like a fellow, which is...
Truly, yet they doubt it's not.
It's because he doesn't have like, he's a special.
project agent. Never a guy. So I...
Thank you.
in that position is
not accurate.
He is... yeah. He's kind of...
kind of like VP of engineering.
But I think it's a new way.
So anyway, but he has like a whole
team that he's building. I don't know on
like the pursuit says I know.
what like proposals would even look like at the tr-
But he's connected to a million places.
So I can certainly pass along if you have a resume.
I mean, I can obviously point him to LinkedIn.
Not from like a job position.
just under or a website.
Whatever.
Okay, yeah.
Just let him know what you're doing.
that if they needed any consulting thing need anyone to just like
kind of look into things. So tell me what what would your
deal and I actually have something in five minutes in this
sucks but we can talk on the phone anytime or whatever you can.
always text me and be like, "You free?" Yeah.
But if you, what is like, tell me your perfect class.
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
Yeah, no.
idea how many times I would be like you don't get it.
I mean, no, and I would say also that they
were promised different things through the Alliance through Sea.
They were promised that we're just going to hand you.
work, you're going to be able to eliminate.
the cost of pursuits, which doesn't
never paying out, right? Like that never worked out. They had to do
It was almost more like these big group.
and waves and sidewalks and
heavy lift. So yeah, he was very frustrating.
He's like, well, that was going to be part of, you know,
we get rid of all of the--
roles and in offsets this rebase.
program and but.
That was fake.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yes.
That's awesome. That's literally like what I'm doing.
I mean, we should talk.
Literally, yeah, so.
doing. I've created a couple of models.
modules for various industry types.
So basically--
like you have your dash, and that's I'm gonna be demoing it.
it to this VC team.
literally like it yeah.
you select your industry and then you can select
like if it's higher ed, it's like APP-A.
standards, right? And then, you know, you could
go in and tweak and do like up.
upload a full campus or upload a single business.
building by building and do, you know, like, my--
a laboratory and it's to this stand.
it's actually ISO even though it's APPA.
either so you can have like kind of nested thing.
But anyway, that's awesome. That's exactly where I think
the market is. I believe that
these small middle businesses don't
know what they don't know and they are overwhelmed particularly.
blue color like H back restoration.
companies, they're just like not, they're not going to.
compete in this market without having someone like you
and say, "Hey, did you know you could do these things?"
things to automate and be more efficient and competitive.
in this world.
Hold on one second.
I just got a text that might push my next meeting back.
Oh, good. What else can I do?
say to okay so what I was gonna say is that you
will love the write-offs.
Bye.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's the only good news.
I created an inner.
interactive like module thing for
tax planning.
late, by the way. I just did it. I should have done it last year.
But it's really interesting, some like,
"Oh, I didn't know that was..."
I could do that. What? So anyway, I
I'll have to, yeah, we can talk about that next time.
But I love it and I believe in you and you're going to
to do great and I will sprinkle your name in your website.
site everywhere. So okay.
Let's talk soon.
Yeah.
Okay.